أه يبدو أن الهجوم الأوكراني المضاد
يسير بشكل أبطأ ويواجه
صعوبات كثيرة أكثر مما قد
يتوقعه الناس، هل يمكن أن تخبرنا من
وجهة نظرك أه لماذا تعتقد أن هذه
الصعوبات هي لماذا تواجه هذه
الصعوبات وماذا تحتاج إلى  حاول
التغلب عليها،
شكرًا لك على هذا السؤال
المهم حقًا،
أود فقط أن ألفت انتباهكم
إلى التغير في الخطابات في جميع أنحاء العالم،
ويسعدني أن أسمع أننا الآن
نناقش الهجوم المضاد في
أوكرانيا.  تتراجع ولكن
تحرر أراضيها تدريجياً وهو أمر
مهم للغاية، لقد كانت لدينا
خطط للبدء في ذلك في الربيع لكننا
لم نفعل ذلك لأنه بصراحة لم يكن لدينا ما يكفي من
الذخائر والأسلحة ولم يكن لدينا ما يكفي من
الألوية المدربة بشكل صحيح على هذه
الأسلحة، ولا يزال
هناك المزيد من المهام التدريبية.
خارج أوكرانيا لكننا
بدأنا وهذا مهم
أه لأننا بدأنا ذلك بعد قليل
يمكن القول وستكون حقيقة مشتركة
يفهمها جميع الخبراء أنها
وفرت لروسيا الوقت لتعدين جميع
أراضينا وبناء عدة خطوط من
الدفاع
وبالتأكيد كان لديهم وقت أكثر
مما يحتاجون إليه لأنهم
بنوا المزيد من تلك الخطوط وكان
لديهم حقًا الكثير من العقول في ملاعبنا
بسبب تلك الوتيرة البطيئة لأعمالنا
الهجومية المضادة التي لم نرغب في
خسارتها  شعبنا وأفرادنا
وجنودنا لم يرغبوا في خسارة المعدات
بسبب ذلك، نعم أفهم أنه من
الأفضل دائمًا معرفة ما إذا كان النصر
سيأتي عاجلاً أم لا، وهذا ما نريده أيضًا
ولكن السؤال هو ثمن هذا
التحرر من هذا النصر، لذا  دعونا لا
نلقي الناس تحت الدبابات في وقت لاحق،
دعونا نخطط لهجومنا
المضاد كما يقترح محللونا، وقد
تم تحرير بعض مناطقنا السكنية
بالفعل، لذلك أنا أؤمن
بانتصارنا، هل هناك تغيير في
الروح المعنوية الروسية، هل لاحظتم
شيئًا حول ماذا؟  الجيش الروسي
نتيجة محاولة التمرد البريجوزية
أعتقد أنه يمكننا أن نفهم ما
يحدث لقوة الجيش الروسي
أو بالأحرى عدم وجود الدافع عندما
نرى ما يحدث للمجتمع الروسي
وشيء من هذا القبيل
يحدث  في ساحة المعركة، يشعرون
بالإحباط،
يمكنك أن ترى أن بوتين فقد
القوة العمودية لسلطته
والخطوات التي اتخذتها براغ
تشهد بوضوح على أن نفس الشيء يحدث في
الجيش في روسيا مع مواطنيهم الذين
لا يتمتعون بالحرية ولأنهم لا يتمتعون بالحرية،  من أنهم
محبطون لدرجة أنهم
لا يرون انتصارات في الحياة المدنية في
الأنشطة العسكرية وحتى أولئك الذين
يدعمون سياسة الحرب
والعدوان للرئيس بوتين
أعتقد أن
هذه النسبة تنخفض، لقد
قمنا بتحليل الخطوات الاحترازية التي
تحدثنا عنها  بخصوص ذلك مع الشركاء
وأقول أن 40 ربما 45 في المائة
من مناطق الاتحادات الروسية
أه من حيث المبدأ أيدوا الخطوات وخطاب
الاحتراز
على الرغم من أنه أه
ممثل للإرهابيين أو حتى
زعيم الإرهابيين نفسه لا يزال
بإمكانك رؤية ذلك  حتى مع
وجود انقسام في المجتمع،
لا توجد وحدة في روسيا الآن ولهذا السبب
نحتاج إلى التحرك